is the reason there are so many people
here in this building sort of buzzing
around with work and creativity because
that's how you came up working on the TV
show and you want to carry that same
Vibe we knew you were coming and those
are
actors am I getting punked we yeah this
is like have you ever seen that movie
The Sting where they have to pretend
it's a casino but it's an off trck
betting place but it's not and they just
hire a bunch of actors so Ashton is in
the grooming van outside he's watching
no uh I my uh I love being around a lot
of people I come from a big family a lot
of uh lot of siblings and a lot of chaos
I like having people around I like um I
I think you've noticed like I just love
bouncing off of people yes um I get a
perverse thrill out of them making fun
of me um I don't know and they they do
uh and you get power from making fun of
them yes yes I grow
Stronger by belittling them
um if someone has an ailment I really go
to town where's your leg oh my God
Conan Jesus don't say that to limpy
um I should learn limpy's Name by the
way that was sleep on a train track
terrible but
but but but I love having people around
and I can't work in a vacuum there are
times if I have to really think about
something I need to go off and be by
myself and I I loath it but then I have
to go back into this we we have this
kebler elf uh tree going here and I
really love um that feeling of bouncing
off I mean I I you know it's so funny
because I've
been uh in comedy for so long and I can
certainly talk a Blue Streak but this
podcast I think what makes it the whole
thing work is if I was here alone it
wouldn't happen but I'm here with son
and Matt and Eduardo and bla and it's I
can bounce off them they can challenge
me uh we can get into it and so there's
a there's a little bit of a chemistry
here that really makes it special so
good that as a guest I was wondering on
the way here like okay what's my what's
going to be my tactic in terms of being
funny occasionally and then and then as
soon as you went I was like oh I don't
have to worry about the carrying the
weight of any of that because to bounce
off of you to give you the idea to set
you up for the big joke makes me feel
like I made the joke yeah you know also
that there's a big thing you learn in in
uh anything is just I don't care how we
get there as long as I'm happy that we
get there there a lot of things I love
about wintertime so cold outside you
gather inside with your Chums yeah your
Bros highfive them yeah and you sit
around a crackling fire and you know
what you do what crack open a cold one
that's it isn't it that's it it is it is
it is y and when you crack open a cold
one you better make sure it's Miller
Light ah the best one sit around there's
a roaring fire maybe we just roasted
some chestnuts probably not no one does
that really no then they crack open a
Miller Light and it makes the
conversation kind of flow everyone's
happy you guys are talking about sports
we are talking about sports we're
talking about hockey we're talking about
uh highly we're talking about trucks
we're talking about cars we're talking
about things we enjoy
we and we have Miller yeah and then it's
got that clean finish oh don't even get
me started the clean finish and it's
only 96 calories 3.2 carbage per 12
ounces again I did those calculations
millerite Great Taste 96 calories go to
millerlite.com to find out delivery
options near you you don't have to go to
the store delivery options or you can
pick up some mirror light pretty much
anywhere they sell beer if you walk in
and they sell beer my guess is they've
got Miller life celebrate responsibly
Miller Brewing Company Milwaukee Wiscon
96 calories and 3.2 carbage per 12 O
like occasionally we'll we'll go and
I'll travel the podcast and um these two
I don't remember your names but I'll get
it you just said it I know and I had it
written on my hand but then it washed
away uh my tears as I was laughing about
limpy um tears of joy and yet you
remembered his name which I know he's
got one leg he got one leg okay yeah I
mean come on get it together you don't
sleep on a train track uh but um he
didn't even hear the train now we can
hear the train but like this on the
train that's the problem with those Asel
so Qui coming on strong fell as sleep on
that train
TR when I woke up I was walking all
wrong walking all wrong walk all all
night long I was walking all wrong with
one leg strong and the other one hanging
just bopping
along walking along okay so you've got
ballot of limpy my ball of Li and what
is it finger Jones finger
Jones wait a minute you you have you
have half an album this is what I do
this is what I do this is where you
should come if I'm lucky you guys go
home tonight take your jacket off and
you go I was walking all WR and your
spouse or roommate says what's that
you're singing I like May started
singing it and it's stuck in my head is
that the walking so sing
more and also in your version the leg is
still there but it's hanging on my
version it's on Tunnel of
Love my god well it's Saturday night I
fell asleep on the
tracks and when I woke up I felt
something different run up and down my
back my right leg was mostly Hanging On
by a
three I love this song it's so good
uh that was a great contribution by
whatever you just did you act like I
didn't Elevate what John did I elevated
what John did no you didn't John was
singing in his barely passable voice and
then I
added that was like a 10 a.m. orgasm I
don't know what you were doing if I
could have an organiz at 10 a.m. I'd be
quite happy sir yeah you're about right
for
me someone's been looking at my
Eyal High time 10:00 a.m. High Time
people want people want to go on a date
I'm like sorry every day begins at 10:30
a.m. if you want to go on a date with me
you got to get your request in before
10:00 a.m. the new Apple watch has a
function that lets you know when John
Mayor is
orgasm and I I didn't I know how to turn
it off One More album it's just on
thereo you can turn it off but you have
to go in to the whole thing and
turn it off so I'll just be walking it
be 10 every morning around 10:00 a.m. it
goes like and I'm like i' say one more
thing with Apple's new exciting Jack
track you can find out when you or your
loved ones are pleasuring themselves so
it's to better time your Amorous
moments we believe that with the with
with a new longer life battery in the
ultra 8 and Jack
track I love the Jack track that's
that's an app
the Jack track Jack you've got two songs
in an app out of this relatively short
discussion what we
do